desde el amanecer ya hay decenas de
personas para cruzar la frontera entre
etiopía y sudán y para aquellos que
huyen de los combates en la región
separatista de tigre se necesita más que
un río para detenerlos
claro eso sí siento tristeza cuando
vuelvo a ver mi casa y todo lo que he
visto en nuestro pueblo y en el camino
hasta aquí
'no way la organización de las naciones
unidas se estima que harán falta cerca
de 200 millones de dólares para hacerse
cargo de los refugiados etíopes estos
podrían llegar a ser más de 200.000 de
aquí a seis meses de acuerdo a la
institución de la basura en los últimos
días hemos visto más de 20.000 personas
cruzar el río para llegar a este
campamento además la onu calcula que hay
más de dos millones de niños necesitados
a causa del conflicto desde principios
de mes las fuerzas gubernamentales
etíopes combaten con el ejército de
tigre un ataque a una universidad del
mec l atribuido a los etíopes por medios
locales causó más víctimas civiles pero
la situación en el terreno es difícil de
verificar tanto para las organizaciones
internacionales como para la prensa más
vastas por se ven tanto como sea posible
las organizaciones de defensa de los
derechos del hombre como amnistía
deberían tener acceso para vigilar la
situación humanitaria
es habitual que cada parte reivindiqué
sus victorias y no comunique sus
derrotas en los últimos días las
autoridades de tigre sin embargo han
reconocido la pérdida de la ciudad
desire en el oeste del país aunque sin
dar mayores detalles